how  are you in this because uh 18 years ago  you died  i was dead i had the same question i bet  you did  i did yeah i was uh i was at home and i  got a  text from lana wichowski the director  and writer and uh  she was like what do you think about  doing another matrix film  and i went what  that sounds amazing but i'm dead  and then she was like are you  and i went do tell  and um  and she wrote a beautiful a beautiful  script a wonderful story and i think  matrix revolution i'm sorry rach matrix  resurrections  it's early  now i'm really glad to be here  resurrection  you got it  and a film that we need  today i feel like a big hook is going to  come in and they wheel you off  the movie is called  [Laughter]  nature's resurrection there you go with  the neo hands exit very good  [Music]